- [Voiceover] So Becca and
I have been talking about
Uncle Tom's Cabin which is
this book from the 1850s
that Abraham Lincoln actually
said started the Civil War.
So how did this book start a war?
So in this video we'll tell
you more about the plot.
But in the previous video
we kind of discussed
what was going on in
the country at the time
and Harriet Beecher
Stowe again was from this
abolitionist family.
She was really deeply effected
by the Compromise of 1850
and the Fugitive Slave Act,
and also by slave auctions.
So this video will get
a little bit more into
the heart of the plot
of the novel which does
have to do with the
family being torn apart.
- [Voiceover] So what was Uncle
Tom's Cabin actually about?
Uncle Tom's Cabin was set
on a plantation in Kentucky
and it starts out with this
kind of group of slaves
that are about to be sold
to other plantation owners.
So Eliza and her son actually run away.
They run up North, so Eliza goes up North
and Uncle Toms is sold down the river.
- [Voiceover] So, Eliza
is trying to make sure
that she and her son are
not separated by being sold.
So she decides that she is going to escape
and take her son with her up to Canada.
But Uncle Tom, he's not actually related,
he is sold in the opposite direction.
He's getting farther away from freedom
by heading down the Mississippi.
When you think about
the geography of slavery
it's a much more urban
environment than some of
the more coastal areas.
So you might be in
Charleston, or you might even
be in Baltimore as an enslaved person.
You might have a pretty
high degree of freedom
and also a possibility of escape either
by crossing the border or by boat.
When you're sold into the
deep South area you are deep
in plantation country
and there might not be
another soul that you could
rely on to help you escape
for 100, 200 miles.
- [Voiceover] And I think
this is really something
that Harriet Beecher Stowe
wants to help point out
in the book, that there
was this sense of doom
for Uncle Tom.
However, his Christian
faith was the only thing
that really kept him going.
He bonded with this young
white woman that he met, Eva,
just about their Christian faith.
And really, reading
his Bible was the thing
that got him up in the morning.
So where were those feelings
about religion coming from?
- [Voiceover] You can definitely see
that Harriet Beecher Stowe is influenced
by her own family's
faith which is influenced
by the Second Great Awakening.
The Second Great Awakening
was this flowering
of religious belief in
the 1830s and 1840s.
It was kind of a reaction
against the Era of Enlightenment
which was what had inspired the founders
of the United States to think
of a more humanist world,
a more rational, scientific world.
People start going to camp meetings,
they have religious revivals.
They experience religious conversions.
And in this time period
there's a shift in thinking
about God in the United States.
If you think back to
the puritans they have
this incredibly punitive
sort of Old Testament
destroyer God, right?
One of the most famous early
sermons in the United States
is sinners in the hands of an angry God,
that at any moment God might
release you into the flames.
Well there's a new emphasis
on Christ-like love
in the early 1830s, 1840s.
New interpretation of
God as being forgiving
and gentle, family oriented,
it's very Victorian.
Where God was seen as this punisher
who condemned most people to hell,
in the Second Great Awakening
there's a new emphasis
on a forgiving, kind family-oriented Jesus
who will save everyone.
That's very incompatible
with the ideas of slavery.
- [Voiceover] Exactly, and I
think that Uncle Tom's Cabin
can really be considered a part
of the Second Great Awakening
because of the way that it
points out these fundamental
inconsistencies and contradictions
between Christian faith
and human bondage.
How could a religion that
says treat thy neighbor
as thyself actually sanction slavery?
- [Voiceover] So Uncle Tom is
this martyr character, right?
He is a devout believer in Christianity
and the forgiveness of God right up until
his very end.
So how does Uncle Tom's
Cabin actually end?
- [Voiceover] Uncle Tom's
Cabin ends with Uncle Tom
is beaten by his overseers.
He's sold through this chain
of different slave families
in the deep South and he
ends up with just a terrible,
terrible slave holder
who requests his death,
actually partially because he was reading
all of this religious text.
[Voiceover] And this slave
owner was named Simon Legree.
And this name, Simon Legree,
has actually stuck with us
in popular culture to
mean a really evil, cruel,
punitive master.
- [Voiceover] The rest of the
family actually meets back up.
Eliza is reunited with
a bunch of other people
that were on the original
plantation and they really
think about Uncle Tom as this
martyr, the hero's death.
He's looked at as this sacrifice
for the cause of freedom.
- [Voiceover] Right, also
Uncle Tom, he dies never having
renounced his Christian faith.
His example of martyrdom
actually leads everyone
who witnesses his death,
including Simon Legree,
to convert to Christianity
and to vow never
to hold slaves again.
- [Voiceover] But I think
the ending of the book
really points out this main theme within
a lot of Second Great
Awakening texts which was that
if you just paid attention
to how you are falling away
from your Christian
commitments then you could get
back on track and maybe
bring people together
by utilizing Christian
faith in a productive
and public way.
- [Voiceover] The book
is published in 1852,
then what happens?
How do people receive this book?
- [Voiceover] We'll talk about
this Tom-mania that ensues
in the next video.